sorry final speaker for the days they
wish Moyes who's a professor of
operations research and computer science
at Cornell and he's going to talk about
city by great and thanks to the
organizers for inviting me the workshop
and give me this chance to talk to you
this is joint work with my current PhD
student Daniel Freund who's here
somewhere and foreign PhD cinto and
nominee and st. Henderson a colleague
and at Cornell so for those of you who
haven't encountered bike-sharing let me
just give you the introduction as far as
what we're talking about bike sharing
systems have become one of the new
features of the modern urban landscape
with stations such as this in New York
City and a map of describing where
stations are throughout New York a
station consists of a sequence of Docs
that k70 this case full and a fleet of
bikes in a user subscriber can rent a
bike at any given point and return it to
another station in the system and in
terms of maintaining the operations for
such a system the real difficulty is the
natural imbalances that result in the
system throughout the day on the left
you see a station completely full on the
right you see a station completely empty
and this of course causes upset users
too as they encounter either the
inability to return a bike or to rent so
I thought I'd give you a flavor of what
traffic in New York looks like by
playing this movie and this is usually
my I can never find my mouse oh there we
go
see oh I see it's visible there
something aha it's visible there even
though it's not visible on my screen and
now I want to go Oh No there we go okay
there so it's one o'clock in the city
it's the city that never sleeps so you
see each of those corresponds to a
station the diameter corresponds to the
number of bikes going in and out it's
color-coded whether we have more
departing or arriving stations and now
you see it's 6:00 a.m. do I dare
oh [ __ ] now I do this again okay I
taught myself a lesson I will not try to
pause it we go back to midnight so it's
midnight and well well wide through and
what you'll see is that they're going to
be pockets of red of especially the
transit centers coming in as we get to
be rush hour it's stuff starting to
there you see around Penn Station and
Port Authority big red in blue you see
the financial district in Midtown East
Village as a residential district you
have big departing and and the rush hour
is now gradually fading off a little
cooling down
it's nice percolating around lunchtime
comes a little bursts more of activity
now comes back down and now as we head
into the afternoon rush the colors are
going to be reversed we have red in
Midtown in the financial district blue
around Penn Station and so forth blue in
the in the East Village as you see the
traffic going down afternoon Russia
actually sends a bit longer than the
morning rush and then gradually things
fade back to
why of the city okay
so that gives you a sense of the day in
the life of New York City's bike sharing
system and what of the great things
about the system is that it completely
records all the actions that happen we
have complete data on everything that's
happening in the system every time a
bike gets gets removed by a user we know
which users are moving which bike and
returning it to which station that much
later as the movie showed we have
heaviest usage between 6:00 and 10:00
a.m. and in the morning in between 4:00
and 8:00 p.m. in the evening and really
the question is amidst the chaos of the
rush hour there's really little we can
do but we'll talk a little bit of a some
things we can do to sort of improve
performance but especially overnight
between midnight and 6 a.m. we have a
real window of opportunity to set the
system of how do we actually model what
makes good performance and how do we
actually plan to take well and in fact
the tools that we've developed and been
working closely with New York City Bike
Share citibike are really in day-to-day
use the target levels that are currently
aimed for it's the stations throughout
New York City station are really coming
out of these models and then there's a
question of you know what how life
interferes with that so this is a
stochastic modeling question so we start
out with a historical data and from that
we're gonna make the following
simplifying assumption we're just going
to assume a Poisson model of both
renting and returning so for each given
station we assume arrival rate for for
people renting and a separately
exogenously we assume a Poisson rate for
return we're gonna think about each
station is a continuous-time markov
chain and the metric that we're going to
establish to drive all of these things
is to consider the expected number of
upset people that are generated by the
the realization of traffic and why are
you upset you're upset because you go to
rep you arrive to rent and there isn't a
bike there you arrive to return and
there isn't a dock there okay so that's
the basic model another real you know
somehow realization as I talked about
the states of the Markov chain for a
given station corresponds to the number
of bike
either zero up to the capacity of that
station currently being filled and we
have a cost function for measuring the
ability to if we start a given station
it's its style time I there are at this
point of course it could be weighted
cost associated with expected number of
occurrences of an empty or a station for
arriving rental or arriving return
that's full so again you know sort of
drilling down just what that cost
function is focusing on only one of
those two terms we're going to take the
expectation of the number of times that
the rate times the probability that the
station is empty conditioned on the fact
that this chain started at given state I
in terms of how many bikes were there
initially okay so so one easy analysis
we're just currently now I'm saying
assuming constant arrival and rent
renting and return rates on the expected
number of accustomed expected number of
upset customers that objective function
is going to be convex so this really
means that I have if I think about
designing the allocation problem at 6
a.m. of the following very simple convex
allocation problem I have a budget B of
a now total number of bikes I get to
allocate X sub s bikes to a given
station s and I have a cost associated
with the expected number of expected
upset customers for that allocation and
of course that allocation is limited by
the capacity of that station okay very
simple model the way you define cost on
the previous slide I was assuming the X
was always taking integer values I said
I said it's not well I mean so really
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
think about an integer envelope it's
actually this optimization problem we
can show is optimize by integer and it's
actually was well known that you have
integer Optima
okay so I can fluff between the two at
no cost so you can do that but I thought
sort of to bring reality into play let
me show you two pictures
this on the left is the state of New
York on a recent spring day at midnight
and this is the state at 6:00 a.m. and
I've color-coded the stations whether
it's red meaning that it's far from your
6:00 a.m. optimum and lighter
corresponds that it's close to the 6:00
a.m.
optimum and if you stare at that map
you're going to unfortunately see
precious little change of how much we're
actually evolving between where things
stand at midnight and where things stand
that's the sheer volume with the current
means of rebalancing the sheer ability
to go from how things are at midnight to
where they are is is really just not
we're not moving nearly enough bikes so
that's just one sort of thing to bear in
mind so one question is to go back and
say well the way the New York system was
set up and it's true for most of the
systems that we it's not that these
stations are actually drilled into the
ground they actually consisted of
modules and you can actually adapt the
capacity to some extent of this of the
docks so you can ask the question of
given what we know about the system now
did we actually set up the right system
can we reset the docks and in different
capacities so as that we can actually do
things much better so if you think about
that convex program really I mean all of
a sudden I mean all I'm just telling you
is instead of thinking this is being
input think of this as now being a
decision variable and now add a second
constraint which simply says I have a
total allocation of docks and how do I
want to allocate them across all of the
the stations in the system
and the first proposal that that didn't
work with Shane and Owen considered
exactly what I did up until this point
with constant arrival and return rates
and and thinking of this we could prove
convexity results in terms of the number
of the empty docks and full docks which
is the same thing as sort of allocation
of capacity and bikes and we could solve
the LP and then coming to bobbies
question I solve the LP and I keep my
fingers crossed that once I add that
second constraint I actually don't have
an integral 'ti theorem and all of a
sudden I may in fact they what happened
and you know this is the the power of
wishful thinking is at least in terms of
handling the models that we were we were
doing on the data sets we were doing we
never encountered non integrality but
nonetheless that we were maybe skating
on thin ice so you mean okay so there's
a whole I mean I think you're getting it
one thing is that there's no reason to
think that behavior isn't a function of
the system design and and that's that's
that that is fun I mean I agree that
that's an interesting question offline I
might be willing to think about on tape
I'll be willing to tell a story about
how some things were managed which is
the height of managing public
expectation would but so this is this is
clearly going to be an issue but we can
still say let's make that assumption
let's see what kind of different design
we actually lead to yes I
you can hear absently know how many
bikes are in the slot so they will never
go to an empty one if you want to take
one they never go to full one if they
want to return one so there are apps but
it's still I mean so and there's a
question of how do I actually estimate
the those arrival in return rates
they're not low actually don't believe
they're low I mean they're they're
significant effects but let's live with
the day that we have in their ways that
I mean I don't want to take time now but
I'm happy to talk offline of how we can
use the fact that we can somehow time
slice the day to get better estimates of
latent demand but sort of really trying
to understand what latent demand is is
actually a really interesting questions
and I think it's it's great unexplored
territory okay so so one question is by
definition everybody would be happy
so one question I mean I mean part of I
mean we started doing this planning
we're really thinking about trying to
plan for the morning rush hour and
really being able to do substantial
moving in the middle of the day and we
were you know thinking that it and that
was really the driving force by I was
sort of at all reasonable to think about
constant arrival and return rates but
even within receivers expect this
we compared what we got versus a
simulation optimization model of trying
to do a local search for the right
allocation and the simulation
optimization based on doing this local
search could improve things and you
could ask well why is that and the
answer is that we've made this
exhaustion as' discussion about how
those are renting and return rates go
and one thing we know is that if you
know if it runs if bikes run out
upstream they're not going to get
returned downstream in the same kind of
way and so thinking about the complete
decoupling in this way is going to be
problematic in that there are certainly
systematic ways in which the modeling
fails
in in in doing so and that was are the
kinds of things that were exploited in
in the simulation optimization so so one
thing that another sort of highlight
along the way in terms of sort of
understanding our own modeling is to
look at so what this chart is showing is
this is the time of day and this is the
number of bikes in a particular station
at East 27th Street and 1st Avenue and
you can you know stare at the morning
rush for a while it's a one-week cycling
through and you see variability from day
to day somedays looking very different
than others that probably is probably a
function of rain would be my gut
reaction but if you look at those a few
days and you look at that 6 through 10
p.m. that doesn't look like constant
lambda no I mean that all you have this
you know really steady uptick in the
number of bikes of the station and then
a complete depletion starting maybe
around 8:00 between 8 and 8:30 you have
this complete turnaround even though
it's completely within the the morning
rush and that highlighted this is
perhaps an extreme example it happens to
be in front of a Bellevue Hospital there
may be other reasons why things happen
there but that is a you know a very
clear point that making this assumption
about the time invariant rates is is not
so healthy another kind of interesting
phenomenon is this station I'll come
back to later at Hudson and Reid you see
the allocated number of stations and if
you look at the behavior I mean in some
sense this is just a way over
capacitated station that we just never
see it emptying out and we'll come back
to that maybe later
so so the natural thing is let's go to a
more robust model let's think about that
we partition the day into half-hour in
time intervals and within each time
interval we'll assume constant renting
and return rates gives us a little bit
more sophistication and let's see if we
can carry things things forward and
there are a variety of things to happen
we want to make sure that we can
actually do the cost estimation in the
time airing rates that the things that
were true
and need a little bit more work there's
this question of the LP which has been
magically okay
in this problem but maybe life will go
hard and it's also as I think about
doing this time division I'm actually
growing the problem by a factor of 20 or
so and so all of a sudden scale may come
into play and make care about running
time in terms of understanding the cost
structure for time varying rates are a
series of constant rate Poisson /
piecewise way that's relatively easy
standard stochastic dynamic programming
can allow us to extend one period into a
multi period setting that if I think
about the cost to go if I've already
inductively computed what the cost from
period k plus one's the end of the day
is I now have an additional constant
rate here if I think about the
distribution of bikes here and the
probabilities that that infers in terms
of how the bikes will be after one more
period that allows us to just do a
standard dynamic programming recurrence
to compute what the the next period is
and I can work backwards and compute the
expected cost over an enum you know in a
polynomial number of periods okay so so
we were again what is the problem that
we're interested we want for given that
cost function which is driven in this
underlying way we want to allocate
optimally bikes and docks so as to
minimize the total number of upset
system upset customers and here's the at
least I won't prove it but believes that
one stated theorem is that a very simple
greedy algorithm actually produces the
optimal allocation of bikes and docks in
this setting the greedy algorithm works
as follows think about it it's taking
all the stations with zero docks and
zero bikes and while you but have both
bikes and docks available to you figure
out a the best place throughout the
system to add a bike in a dock somewhere
in the system or simply add an extra
empty dock somewhere in the system in
terms of the most improvement in terms
of the overall cost objective and keep
going until you run out of either bikes
or docks if you have no docks left
terminate otherwise if if there are
docks you either add an empty dock or an
empty dock together with reallocating
one of the allocated bikes where the
improvement is greatest and this gives
you an optimal allocation okay sort of
in pictures so the first piece just
simply says look where you have a bike
in a dock or a bike move it where it's
the best you have you either end up with
extra bikes extra bikes leftover extra
docks leftover if you have extra docks
leftover you're gonna either allocate
one extra dock to one of the stations or
else you're going to allocate one extra
dock but you're going to actually move
one of the existing bikes into it in the
latter case you terminate so just as
greedy algorithms are often driven in
terms of their optimality proofs by sub
modularity results things of marginal
decreasing returns the analogous kind of
generalization that's going to be
driving there's a notion of multi
modularity that was introduced by Hayek
so if I think about a plot where each of
these represents one of the solutions
and here's my number of empty docks and
here's my number of full docks multi
modularity says that if I think about
the and maybe I'll put these lines up if
I think about how much the additional in
this case empty dock improves as I move
one you know further right in the thing
keeping the number of full docks there
the improvement of the addition of an
additional empty dock decreases in its
effect as I go forward similarly if I
look at vertically if I increase the
number of full docks relative to a given
base I have decreasing marginal returns
and here if you think about what the
diagonals that represents the constant
total number of docks and so we have a
similar result there and it's completely
dual if I think about interchanging the
role of the number of empty docks the
number of full docks they're going to be
similar marginal decreasing improvements
required for that and that's what's
meant by multi modularity see satisfying
all of those conditions and what we can
do is show that for every realization
that these inequalities
hold for our system and that that's
sufficient to prove optimality and I
really don't have time to explain the
proof but prove it we do and so one
thing you can ask is did I mean we were
somehow motivated to this by this
contrast between what we could see from
what the model predicts versus what a
simulation optimization setting does and
the nice thing is that as a in this case
the simulation optimization which has
the downstream effects built into it no
longer actually we can improve off of
off of there so that the the the
mathematical optimum is actually serving
as a good guide and one thing that is
true is that the you know the running
time of computing this greedy optimum
you still have to work to get those
costs off of solving the stochastic
dynamic program but in terms of what
will work was involved because of the
underlying solving and ex-convicts
program that's gone my so I have like
five oh I hope you give me okay because
I know I did start late so okay good
so I have a number of vignettes of
various things that come into play and
I'll see which of them fit so this was
this other station that I talked about
is sort of being over capacitated and
one of the questions that one can ask is
that I mean if you sort of think about
this sort of Markovian process of what
happens to traffic over time that one
can consider the question of suppose we
didn't touch we didn't do any
rebalancing we just tried to understand
how the fleet evolves as I watched
traffic go and then I can say that if
I'm really not doing any rebalancing and
if you looked at that original graph I'm
practically not doing any rebalancing at
all I may be doing a little but it's
it's not a substantial amount you know
what's the I can separately think about
what are the steady state right
allocations and then I can optimize the
dock so that the steady state is good
and I can have that as yet another
auxilary all optimist
problem so this is a table which shows
exactly those kinds of results so on the
one hand I can say let's think about the
optimal allocation according to the
algorithm of bikes and docks and let's
not do any rebalancing and let's think
about what that means in terms of total
number of upset customers that means or
I can think about as I'm thinking about
that steady-state and I'm and I'm
looking what happens in the steady state
of what that's going to me and I'm not
doing any rebalancing or I could even do
a little bit more and I can optimally
choose the configuration of the system
that is allocate docks so is to do
what's best for for the steady-state and
notice that those two numbers are not
very different on the other hand for the
allocation that's currently in place I
can equally well understand what's the
cost steady States going forward and you
see that's really a lot worse Oh
about 30% worse and then I can even
contrast and suppose that I put all the
resources in the world to do rebalancing
and for each of those configurations I
measure the cost if you know every
midnight I go back and I rebalance back
to the optimal configuration at 6:00
a.m. and the point that I want to drive
home here is that for the current way in
which dock allocation has been done if I
compare what the performance of the
system is like with doing all the
rebalancing in the world overnight it's
actually still worse than for either of
these two system designs setups
and not doing any rebalancing at all so
I mean this is a you know a huge
take-home message in terms of where
things are now there are poet notes to
say that the you know math can drive the
design of the system is is no neglecting
a whole range of political realities
which can be summarized in the one we're
at Brooklyn
Brooklyn has to get its fair share which
is not its fair share and but but
nonetheless it points out some of the
issues that are at play here and that's
just iterating the points that I just
made one can also measure what each of
these kinds of solutions do in terms of
the rebalancing cost of how and if I
wanted to actually go from how the
distribution looks like at midnight to
what it looks like it's 6:00 a.m. and
think about the effects of doing that
the allocations that are done according
to the city state actually incur much
lower rebalancing cost as well so so in
substance we get that win and one of the
things that gets point out is whether I
do it based on the steady optimized for
the steady state solution or whether I
do it according to I mean we optimize
according to theory whether I compare it
to the one-day optimum or whether I
compared to the current allocation in
either case that station which was over
capacitated from both of those models
comes in with much lower capacity
okay so I have a few minutes maybe five
minutes left and I want to sort of
briefly touch on other issues that that
have come up in the things that we're
doing one question which I want to talk
about at all is that but but we're in
the process of providing them a new tool
for exactly how to do the detailed
routing for overnight rebalancing again
guided by the same cost metrics we've
done build tools we're now on the second
version for mid Russ rebalancing one of
the things that had a dramatic effect on
actual system performance are things
called Corral's which allow an effect
for dynamic capacity expansion mid day
and one thing that took place this
summer is an incentive scheme sort of to
push users to take good rides for the
system and the question then if what's
the right incentivizing scheme let me
say a couple words about mid rush
rebalancing for rebalancing within the
rush hour the primary tool that has been
used over this evening is this this
device on the right it's a large
tricycle that has the capacity to load
anywhere this one I think holds six but
but there are versions that hold as many
as twelve city bikes at a time and you
can bicycle between them they're narrow
so they don't have to actually take a
lane of traffic and you can actually
shuttle back and forth between a pair of
stations and the idea is that you want
to pair up saturated stations in starved
stations and have this trike go back and
forth so as to shift some of the bikes
back and forth mid rush-hour and one
question is well I have I only have so
many of these trikes how do I allocate
them that and what we're going to do is
still think about choosing a matching so
as to exactly optimize the same
objective we want to improve what the
overall objective is by doing this this
displaced kind of thing we're gonna have
to in effect couple two of the
continuous-time markov chains that a
pair of stations and and then produce a
matching for example this is the kind of
output that results for nine trailers
and again we're going what it involves
is computing an update for that and
involve
for a given pair of Sage's we're going
to create an edge which effectively has
as its weight the improvement associated
by putting a trailer between then and of
course we want to max okay weight
bipartite matching so as to achieve that
one of the most frustrating things in
all of this work is that the New York
City set up what has to have been the
world and no I mean most cities are
confused in North America are configured
as one of the world's stupidest pricing
plans that it's by and large and
overwhelming fraction of traffic is
driven by annual subscribers an annual
subscriber in New York pays a hundred
and fifty dollars for an all-you-can-eat
access to the system the highest using
twenty percent of the users do more than
eighty percent of the traffic and
they're getting under a buck rides in a
city where the subway costs 275 so so
this is really excuse me one hundred and
fifty five dollars and so this is really
not the right way to do it and one of
the things that we've been trying to do
is is develop an incentive scheme so as
to in front some sense create an
alternative currency so that we can in
fact add value for riders doing you know
in terms of differentiated pricing but
in recent work and I don't really have
time to talk about in any detail but I
suggest you talk to both Daniel and to
Doris who are both here and work with
Sid Banerjee recent colleague you know
are at Cornell developed a queueing
model for taking Derek pairwise demand
and value distributions and devising
efficient algorithms to find prices that
maximize a given objective and produce
approximation results not just for for
any of the sort of standard and maximize
the social welfare revenue throughput
but also things like Ramsey pricing
which involved by criteria results there
are a lot of things that are still going
on things from one of the things you
think should have been figure
early is I give you a set of demands but
what's the right size of the fleet for a
given capacity this of the system if you
have too many bikes then you're gonna
have stock outs for docks if you have
too few bikes you're not gonna meet
demand and it's actually an interesting
question so as to have good models to
actually do that well some things can be
inferred from the things we do but
whether that really probably the
simulation optimization approaches is
probably a more effective way and really
getting a hands on it in Tel Aviv the
system is on the grid in New York it
runs on solar running on solar means
actually it runs on batteries that have
to be replaced and that gives rise to a
range of sort of repair questions and
indeed there are a number of interesting
stochastic optimization problems that
arise from just the management and
detection of broken equipment either
bikes or docks and and or users and
that's certainly a source of things that
are will be working on going forward and
in general as I indicated I mean this is
a great know field to play in in terms
of we have the data is there and the
question of trying to have measures for
thinking about system performance and
and thinking about it not just to the
station level but at the data at the
neighborhood level and there's still a
lot of work left to be done both on the
modeling and the computation side so
with that reception
is there a gaming element like the more
you improve the system the more people
use it yes I mean I don't know about a
gaming it's just you know natural human
behavior that I mean I mean what are the
things that's happening in terms of so
to the ground moving underneath us is
that when it was originally launched it
was contained to from Central Park South
to the bother to the lower Manhattan in
a small piece of Brooklyn it's now but a
much bigger footprint in in Brooklyn and
even pieces of Queens in Long Island
City and and and now this year it's all
the way up to the 90s by next year it's
supposed to go up to one hundred and
thirtieth Street and you know you think
about you know neighborhoods that many
of us have traversed I mean the range of
what happens at a place like Columbia
you know comes into an interesting class
of things and there are different kinds
of user demand patterns that get
illuminated by the evolving state of the
system so yeah I mean this is I mean
this is life in the transient you know
two small stations which are close to
each other are better or worse than one
larger which is like the south
there there probably I mean I mean my
uninformed um thing is that there are
reasons why too small are better I mean
it's a question of what's the objective
the objective is simply in terms of SATA
starving users psychologically there's
no reason why you would say they of
course won one station we'd better it
must be more deterministic you're
aggregating demand but somehow there are
psychological things that come into play
that make it not clear I mean but but
but that's that's assuming the exogenous
demand which is not clear given given we
know what we know about human behavior
in pieces of what's happening known as
all this is is I mean so they're kind of
like opposite but they're not exactly
for in a variety of ways so it's if life
were perfectly antisymmetric there would
be no problem or if there would be far
fewer problems the problem is that it's
not perfectly antisymmetric I mean in
fact the worst case you know the sort of
the nightmare scenario is is is not the
sort of steady state but the late
afternoon thunderstorm when all of a
sudden bikes are really not a thing but
that's a whole other you know can of
worms but but it's it certainly would
simplify matters if it were always the
case that forever you know everyone used
it in both directions but but a they
don't and they're stochasticity in the
system as well so that even if I told
you that that you know with with high
probability that happens the question is
you're still going to have independent
events that are going to have the visit
the statistical variations that are
gonna cause the complexity of what
really happens in a given instantiation
we should all have wine and cheese